I guess I always honor to being here for
the race my dream was to be a big leader
with the grace and I accomplished that
so to me it's like I'm living the dream
right now and that's when I got my
tattoo literally saying that okay I had
to I had to because everything was like
it was meant to be at that point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ozzy what's going on we are here at good
kitchen and marketing Marietta Georgia
why this place of all places well I have
to thank you guys here because this is
one of the best breakfast lunch spot I
come to what are the top things on the
menu that we should get you mentioned
breakfast so breakfast I go always with
plain pancakes I like plain Bank some
three Italian meatballs okay that's what
I like pancake and meatballs meatballs I
really like the pancakes okay my
favorite spots for pancakes now is this
the go-to place all the time you come
back home from a road trip and we have
seven games here I come here at least
three four times almost that week now
obviously Atlanta is your home away from
home this is where you play this is
where you won but this isn't where
you're from so I'm originally from
Curacao right and where is Curacao
located Curacao is in South America it's
closed located to Venezuela Aruba and uh
I mean just being born from there and
growing up there it's one of the best
things you know you're on the island but
there's so much fun stuff to do you go
off-roading you go fishing swimming all
those great stuff so being in Curacao a
little bit of the knowledge I know about
it and we're sitting here speaking in
English but this isn't your native
language I know you know what what's
your native language what's the native
language spoken and curious my native
language is popular spoken there Aruba
and Bonaire okay so those ABC islands
all right that's where it's mainly
spoken English has to come into the mix
one is English so introduced when you go
to school it's mandatory to learn these
languages okay so you go to school you
still learn in Pokemon too you know
you're a little kid you start in stock
and then you have English Spanish Dutch
if we're going to eat here and I want
you to order in papimento how do you
order what you're gonna order today so
the pancakes the meatballs okay let's do
the pancake meatballs with bacon and
eggs okay so I will say that means good
morning
just like that it translates straight
through so it'll be the pancakes with
the eggs yeah pancake with the eggs with
bacon and meatballs
[Music]
do you watch baseball yes
take that time yes favorite team growing
up favorite team so me and my
grandfather used to watch every night
baseball games and we watch the Braves
in the Dodgers okay every time nice
that's what his favorite teams were so
praise became my favorite team because
of my grandfather one of my favorite
teams as well one of my favorite players
also Curacao native Andrew Jones you
guys played together was he a reason you
know that you liked watching a brace
your grandfather a big reason why we
always watch the Braves because of Henry
Jones you know you got Hensley marylands
too yeah melons but Henry Jones
everybody was when I grew up everybody
so I even have a picture of it how old
were you when you got five years five
years old just turned five on that same
day and my dad surprised me with a
pleasure with that so so at that time
you're five years old and Curacao is is
growing and getting on the map the
baseball map got Andrew Jones doing his
thing in the major league but you also
have the Little League World Series
being represented by by your country the
Senior League World Series like teams
from your country players that you might
know or know of are playing at the
highest level for the world to see was
that influential for you yes it was yes
it was so like I said starting with
Henry Jones but then you heard of Amazon
Simmons coming up Roger bernadina all
these guys coming and profar scope and
out of nowhere something was like in my
mind like hey I want to be a major
league baseball player one day too
Ozzie Albie's one of the most aggressive
hitters in all of baseball the slide
[Applause]
it'll take me through
last year the Braves are getting hot we
enter the playoffs
how was that just from a mental
standpoint for you personally for the
team you know how did that all unfold
the year before we lost in uh in the NLC
as well
and we were like okay this year is our
year yeah we have to go for it and we
have to win the whole thing we're not
going to just be in it we have to win so
going into it mentally you know you work
the whole season for these moments yeah
so when we got there it's all about
let's go take care of what we need to
take care of don't think about the rules
we're gonna face hold up all the people
the teams let's go just focus on us
we did that
and like everybody saw that's what got
us to the World Series now we're here
together let's win together that's what
we did so you you win you won together
you won together how you gonna do it by
yourself no chance how was the
celebration
you win the World Series this is a hope
and dream of kids that want to play
baseball and now you've just
accomplished it just get to the World
Series getting there was the biggest
thing for me because you always see this
on TV you've never been there physically
like oh yeah World Series but being
there as soon as I stepped in Houston I
remember first game I look around I was
like this is it were you nervous no no
okay I was excited excitement like okay
here is what I worked my whole life for
the ring yeah and
went in I remember getting getting the
first law against stolen base on like
this has really happened I couldn't
believe it so I was I was the one the
most amazing moment in my life how was
it when you went back home and I went
back home they did hopefully just for me
as soon as you land as soon as I land
they put me on on one of those big cards
and just drive me through the whole
Curacao
[Music]
there were also four other
Curacao players that played for the
Braves before you yes Randall Simon
Anderson Simmons Andrew Jones jire jerks
you're the fifth
you get a sixth Curacao exactly
yes joins you on the Braves I remember
him calling me and say hey I signed with
the bridge they're perfect let's go and
let's go to win the World Series this
year together that's what that's our
goal right now and you got to Atlanta I
showed him some cool restaurants we we
go together we eat we enjoy we travel
we're the team we sit together talk you
know always have fun with a group of
guys playing Uno and all this stuff on
the plane but
I really like the way first time I ever
happened to me too having a Curacao guy
on the same team so it was actually a
great moment right for him to be on the
team he came he actually came to the
restaurant here with me okay you brought
him here we ain't here together what did
you remember what you had to eat that
pancakes and everything yeah he loves he
loves pancakes also and you know he's a
big boy he likes to eat his own thing
winning one is great but winning two
we're being better Kimmy has a ring with
the Dodgers you have a ring with the
Braves you two getting two rings
together it'll be amazing it's gonna be
the biggest parade and kill yourself
if that happens it will be amazing we
gotta go get it together now we're on
the same team Let's Make History let's
go continue to do it and live and live
stream
always always
I will always do that keep living the
dreams
and thanks for the recommendation I'm in
Marietta I'm coming to good kitchen and
market and I'm gonna get the pancakes
next time yes please you'll enjoy